ho sempre saputo
che prima o poi nella vita avresti
più o meno dall'età dei tre anni sapevo
malapena a impugnare una matita e
scarabocchiare le mie prime parole su un
pezzo di carta e me lo ricordo benissimo
il mio primo tentativo allo zero tutti
gli altri bambini dormivano
perché allora del pisolino pomeridiano e
io da sempre ero insomma la bambina è
tuttora lo sono come essa pur di
mettermi a tacere
mi mise in mano la penna che aveva nel
taschino e non potendo uscire a
procurarsi un blocco da disegno a
tenermi buona
lì davanti a me un fazzoletto di carta
per scarabocchiare c super disegnarci su
è bene lì ebbi il colpo di genio creare
il mio primo capolavoro sfruttare le
pieghe di questo fazzoletto di carta
come linee per separare le vignette di
quello che sarebbe stato il mio primo
libro la versione a fumetti della fiaba
di cappuccetto rosso e lo feci il caso
volle o meglio la sfiga in questo caso
vuole che in quei giorni avesse anche
raffreddore ai bambini malati
la stessa insegnante che aveva creato il
genio proviamoli all'istante facendomi
il sociale nato proprio in quel
fazzoletto cancellando per sempre è
probabilmente la possibilità di
realizzare nella vita un vero e proprio
caso editoriale
non so bene cosa mi abbia poi condotta
effettivamente da realizzare la versione
a fumetti di cappuccetto rosso a
scrivere sachs un saggio scientifico che
esplora le dinamiche nascoste del nostro
fai sesso
non è dato sapere insomma poi crescendo
si cambia poi mi perdonino i miei
genitori però probabilmente anche di
sonia deve aver giocato un ruolo su
questo interesse stanno fatto che oggi
sono qui e volevo condividere con voi
alcune delle idee che mentre mi dedicavo
a questo lavoro che poi si è
concretizzato vero libro che avete
capito tutti non parla di cucina alcune
idee che ho visto è letteralmente
precipitare cadere essere rase al suolo
dalla documentazione e devo dire che non
poche di queste idee ci condizionavano
anche probabilmente sotto le lenzuola
che magari stanno condizionando anche
voi cos'è come mentre lavorava questo
libro ho realizzato che alcuni degli
aspetti e gli aspetti del nostro fare
sesso che pensavo fossero scontati
banali e non meritevoli di attenzione
dal punto di vista scientifico invece
erano stati esplorati da molto da vicino
ma molto da vicino da scienziati
estremamente curiosi e non solo con gli
strumenti classici della medicina in
laboratorio della medicina anche della
diagnostica ma anche e rompendo nella
stampa dal vivo sul più bello magari
interrompendo donà e siccome ho deciso
di partire in modo molto soft
innanzitutto coinvolgervi in un piccolo
giochino niente distinto vorrei solo che
pensate per qualche secondo al vostro
partner
in particolare di baciarlo se non
l'avete pensate al vostro vicino
insomma tutti ne avete uno
maiale carino non si sa mai nella vita
la domanda che dovete porvi e mappe
incline rail a testa per baciarle per
non scontrarsi in auto a naso con questa
persona a destra sinistra allora stupida
mi fa ridere
eppure c'è chi nel mondo scientifico se
l'è posta in laboratorio
c'è chi nel mondo scientifico ha
trascorso dei mesi la propria attività
professionale
il comando col giornalista la mano a
osservare le coppiette salutarsi negli
aeroporti e nelle stazioni o nel
pacchetto sotto casa
fini statistici o per lo meno questo è
quello che ci dicono gli scienziati
questi fini statistici si compensano
però in questo momento di dire che più o
meno due terzi delle 200 persone che
vedono in questa stanza in cui non
abbiamo la testa verso destra
solo un terzo verso sinistra è sin qui
chi se frega se pensa che la cosa
divertente sono le ipotesi che gli
scienziati hanno elaborato per spiegare
questo comportamento una delle quali mi
ha particolarmente colpita in mostra
anche e cioè quella che fa derivare
questo comportamento addirittura dal
nostro orientamento dai nostri movimenti
durante lo sviluppo fetale cioè quando
eravamo ancora nel pancione della mamma
e quindi l'idea è bellissima un'idea
questa insomma il nostro modo di baciare
potrebbe esistere in un certo senso già
prima ancora di venire al mondo bene
questa è una co tesi l'altra che sto per
dirvi non dovete mai pensarci prima di
baciare qualcuno soprattutto se il bacio
è un limone ma è la seconda ipotesi
appunto e quella che fa risalire questo
comportamento alla scelta ai due seni
che la nostra ma mandamento della fazi
broni baci a tutti direi anche le
ginocchia tremano gli occhi brillano il
cuore falsità
tutto vero quando qualcuno ci piace
queste sono le normalissime reazioni
fisiologiche del nostro organismo
rovinerò anche quelle perché di fatto se
le nostre ginocchia tremano è perché c'è
un neurotrasmettitore che schizza in
circolo proprio quando qualcuno ci
attrae romanticamente o sessualmente e
che rende non ci rende ci dà la
sensazione di avere le gambe leggermente
più deboli del solito quindi le
ginocchia trema gli occhi brillano di
brino ma davvero perché la bocca mina
che ha un'altra delle molecole che la
cui concentrazione si impegnino a quando
qualcuno ci piace se mai vi sa proprio
cosa da fare è leggermente le nostre
pupille contrario è leggermente le
nostre palpebre e in questo modo si ha
l'impressione che lo sguardo della il
nostro sguardo un maggior quantitativo
di luce anche se solo per una piccola
frazione di secondo
quindi gli occhi britti e il cuore e il
cuore mattel accelera aumenta la
frequenza del suo battito e lo fa per
spingere più sangue agli stretti del
corpo in particolare per ossigenare
meglio i nostri muscoli
magari non sono usciti di casa pensando
bene anche stasera non si conclude
niente però poi deciso che se qualcuno
ci piace dubbi supporto l'anti prepara
il corpo l'attività sportiva e magari
torniamo a casa delusi per lui allora
the mist oliva intanto milicia in tavola
attenzione non sopra avola quindi non
scendiamo in dettagli per la mo di cibi
afrodisiaci peperoncino specchio
piccanti a tutti sarà capitato magari
anche contro voglia di beccarsi la cena
etnica e calore sudorazione tachicardia
sensazione di bruciore
tutte cose normalissime quando mangiamo
queste grady e questi ingredienti e
tutte le azioni anche normalissime
quando
facciamo proprio durante l'escalation
della città mento sessuale fino
all'orgasmo
ebbene sembra che sia proprio per questa
analogia che secondo gli scienziati
abbiamo preso considerare questi
condimenti degli afrodisiaci quasi
fossero degli interruttori verso il
desiderio non sono degli analoghi sulle
reazioni fisiologiche del noto siccità
mento sessuale quindi sono una
spiegazione un po diversa da quella che
sinceramente mi aspettavo altro cibo in
questione magari vi starete svelati a
san valentino per comprarle le ostriche
nostri che si trova a colazione se le
sparava 50 così ogni mattina perché lui
aveva da fare insomma aveva tantissime
donne doveva dovevamo tenere botta
ciononostante gli scienziati hanno un po
data la composizione chimica di questo
di questo cibo non trovandovi
all'interno nulla di così fenomenale dal
punto di vista del bel vigore sessuale
del desiderio che secondo gli scienziati
rende ha reso nella storia questo cibo
un afrodisiaco el'aspetto i bivalvi ci
ricordano i genitali femminili ci fanno
con fare lo stesso e quindi un po come
in medicina lo teniamo effetto placebo
la suggestione ciò che ci viene in mente
ciò che ci viene ciò che ci viene in
mente poi va riflettersi precise
risposte biologiche quindi magari ci fa
salire il desiderio
finalmente un analogo maschile dell'oste
che coraggio il principale la banana il
frutto dell'amore come quei cibi
afrodisiaci
si dà spesso per scontato che siamo in
grado di emanare alcune molecole odorose
tali da attirare sessualmente qualcun
altro i cosiddetti feromoni parte questa
cosa è vera
peccato che non sia stata ancora trovata
sugli esseri umani
il romanista suono esistono sono stati
documentati ma in molte specie animali
per esempio gli insetti
l'ape regina è in grado secernendo
queste sostanze di inibire lo sviluppo
dei genitali nelle sue amiche di alveari
nelle operaie perché lei deve essere
l'unica ciò nonostante la scienza ci
dice che qualcuno ha provato a venderti
delle boccettine delle essenze dei
profumi tali da renderli irresistibili
avete speso dei soldi più o meno
inutilmente quando si parla di dio trier
in ambito sessuale
c'è un'unica rima senofane anche rima
però masturbazione che la masturbazione
è una di quelle cose che la storia ci
dice essere nata più o meno con luogo
nel senso che abbiamo reperti
archeologici risalenti addirittura al
tempo delle terne per intenderci dei
veri e propri falli in pietra
anatomicamente perfetti e meritatissimi
dei veri e propri sex toys del film son
per intenderci ciò nonostante la
masturbazione stiamo nel 2017 già solo a
pronunciarla qua dentro tutti rigidi non
è che andiamo in giro per strada dire a
vado masturba insomma è un tema ecco
tutti che ridono e lo fanno tutti lo
fanno uomini e donne lo fanno da sempre
oppure
enti ma questo è sicuramente uno dei
temi che ho incontrato più spesso quando
cercavo insomma di cosa parlare in
questo libro
e se ne parla in continuazione si dà per
scontato che cosa sia cosa serva
tuttavia è uno dei temi più sconosciuti
che ho incontrato è una cosa divertente
è che appena uscito il libro alcune
persone mi fermano ma sono contentissimo
ho letto il libro l'ho letto solo perché
mi hanno detto dalla pagina al dei pali
c'è scritto come trovare il punto g
grazie buttiamo via tutto il resto al
rogo è altra cosa
tutte donne gli uomini al punto si crea
nulla
grazie torniamo a noi punto g tema
abusatissimo ma allo stesso tempo
all'interno della scienza anche il modo
dibattito non è così scontato ci sono
scienziati che litigano sul punto g
parte della tavola quelli che dicono
ragazzi abbiamo la concentrazione di
terminazioni nervose la parete anteriore
della rai nella vagina gli convengono
diverse strutture anatomiche quello al
punto di quell'area il punto g
stimolandolo si hanno degli organi
parecchio intensi in alcuni casi altri
che invece dicono punto g non abbiamo
strumenti a sufficienza non esistono
strumenti tali da definire una struttura
anatomica che possiamo chiamare punto g
non c'è un organo un tessuto che
possiamo chiamare punto g allora il
punto g non esista è un mito moderno ed
è una scusa se siete fra quei mariti che
non troppo
bene rilassatevi perché sono arrivati
all'apice allora probabilmente sono
anche un po sfigata ma io vicini
rumorosi li ho avuti
voi non so però penso di essere l'unica
tutti penso abbiamo udito prima o poi
nella vita a qualcuno che gemeva a
livello magari anche da darci fastidio
il fatto che mentre noi magari in quei
momenti ci interroghiamo se il tipo
chissà come fare ottenuto questo
risultato che fa come fa per genere
quella persona così come gli scienziati
nel loro bella botta che si chiedevano
quale saranno maglia ragioni
scientifiche per le quali le donne
gemono così tanto a letto perché
statisticamente sono le donne a genere
più spesso
questo è un dato di fatto grazie a
questi scienziati curiosi sappiamo oggi
che a jam e se veniamo e sicuramente lo
fanno molto di più le donne come dicevo
non è esclusivamente per comunicare il
nostro piacere il nostro passo di
piacere o il nostro caso ma per esempio
un recente studio inglese racconta come
invece la maggior parte delle donne
dichiari di genere in concomitanza
dell'orgasmo del partner
quando il partner st farina colare e
quindi usando quasi usando la voce come
uno strumento per potenziare le
citazioni del pane per soddisfare per
gratificare il compagno un gesto quasi
ammirevole le loro dita estrema ma c'è
dell'altro perché ho scoperto sempre
scavarmi questi studi che le donne che
dichiarano dichiararono di genere più
spesso più frequentemente però ma anche
le stesse che dichiaravano di fingere
più spesso l'orgasmo e anche le stesse
che dichiarano di avere più timore di
essere tradite dal partner
quindi più gemiti più finzione
dell'orgasmo più bello del tradimento
quasi come se la voce potesse
era avvenuto già per tenersi
accalappiato il compagno serissimi o
sfasciato qualche coppia non lo so
a discolpa del pubblico femminile voleva
sottolineare che altri studi spiegano
invece benissimo come appunto attività
sessuale che di fatto è anche una città
sportiva possa condurre
all'iperventilazione respiro
estremamente falloso e in quel caso è
normalissimo di vocalizzare partono dei
gemiti possono partire degli anni ti
totalmente infrenabile involontari e non
premeditati e direi che questo è un
motivo sufficiente per darci di
beneficio del dubbio e vi ringrazio per
la pensione
[Applauso]